our project
is an immaterial museum that means that
we appear
and disappear that focuses on
re-signifying
the relevance and the beauty of the
family kingdom
for berlin science week we will show two
videos that have been recently made for
the collection of the museo de longo
and have a discussion around them with
the artists and
the teams involved in the production of
both videos
both videos will give highlights on how
can we engage people with science
through art
our main objective as a project the
first one mapuku fool was premiered in
arts electronica
this last september and the second one
is a video of sign language
chilean sign language for mycological
concepts and will be premiered in berlin
science week
our core mission is to break down the
walls between
nature and culture to understand the
human being
as a part of this complex interdependent
system that is nature
i would say the biggest challenge at the
moment
when world politics are focusing a lot
on the economics
is to find funding for cultural projects
to make people
understand the relevance of culture and
art
for social transformation to survive
financially
in a country and in a society that
value less and less arts and culture
i would say that the biggest challenge
besides the funding
is that how can we make people relate to
science
in an autonomous and authentic way how
can we provide
effective tools for them so they can be
really interested in science and not
scared away because of the
cryptic language or complicated
visualizations
and i think we we chose art
as the medium because of its sensorial
and immersive possibilities
and that creates a personal relationship
between the object and the
spectator